Hãy theo một cái hương kêu của PWC thì có đến 3,5% sang hip.
Chào mía thì là việc mà ám dục ESG, ám dục các chiến lược phát triển bình vữ thì đã dút sang hip của họ.
Nên cao được hình ảnh thương hiệu của như là sang biểu,
phải thì không biết là chỉ vấn đề của chia sẻ như thế nào?
Người thế dùng bị nè hỉnh này là bên cạnh,
cái lúc nơi quan tâm về ai tàng tập tán thịn,
để như là sử nống lên của tòa cao.
Hẹ là ôi những không ký,
ôi những mùi nước,
phải thấy dụng bình nè của nè, đúng không phải nè.
Và tán mì tôi phòng chăm người tôi dùng bị nè,
cho rằng họ sẽ lửa trọng,
tương tý lửa trọng những cái sánh thẳng không bao giờ bị thân thịn với mùi chục.
Và tán như vậy, phùi chăm cho mùi chăm,
cho mùi chăm, cho đó thì họ cho rằng là họ sẽ thực hiện và tình ký giận khàn đồng,
như cái giải phép,
để có thể giám thử được những cái lách thải ghê hại trong ngoài lưu chục.
Dùa ra thì cũng thấy đây là mất kêu hội để cho những cái dân nghi,
có thể nắm mắt được xu hướng tưu dòng,
và đù ra được những cái sánh thẳng phù hợp phó lại thị hướng người tôi dùng tình tài.